(exclaiming)
(bouncy music)
- So, I feel like right now,
you're giving me like,
Samara from "The Ring".
I feel like the TV's gonna come on,
and I'm gonna be like, no!
- Please enjoy a pumpkin cookie with a--
(screams)
(screaming)
- Like this a beautiful
bread basket to have.
- [Tan] Oh, my.
- Oh, no.
(screaming)
Oh, that's intense, rude!
- Let's go on a real date.
(exclaiming)
(shouting)
(screaming)
- No.
Ugh.
No.
Henny, no.
Oh, henny.
What's our mission, henny?
Grooming is an evolution, henny,
it's gorgeous, henny, it's Darwin, henny.
Look at that toe, honey.
And this is Manuka honey,
and it promotes skin healing,
even more than normal honey would.
I don't know who gave
your family permission
to all be so cute.
I'm droppin' stuff, it's
okay, we're acting like
it didn't happen, but then
you're right there for the save,
love my Lex.
Let's go.
Yes, I want that, too.
Yes, bitch.
Yes.
Yes!
Yes, yes, yes.
Yes, yes, yeah.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes,
yes, yes, yes!
Yes, Cory! Yes, Cory!
Yes!
(screams) That was gorgeous.
No!
- Maybe?
- Yes, queen!
Yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
Yes!
Yes, queen, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes!
Yas.
Yes.
- You're like Kristi Yamaguchi.
- Yes!
Yes.
Is this your bano?
Wait, let's investigate your bano.
Road trip!
- Jesus take the wheel.
- Got it! (laughs)
- You are not in a lane!
You are not in a lane!
- I'm in a lane.
(laughing)
- Did you just run a light?
- No!
- Just so nervous by all of this.
- I've learned to make
peace with my sudden death.
- Carry my tiny little body
out of this en fuego fire.
- There it is!
- I need to be carried to safety!
- Good morning, Blanche.
- Oh, this is Blanche welcoming
you to the spa, honey.
Hi! How are you guys.
Look at this beautiful man,
who gave you permission?
Yeah, was gorgeous.
Mister Mayor.
And I just don't know if I'd be able
to keep my hands off of you.
So gorgeous.
Oh, you're making my Blanche come out.
- [Karamo] He's 5'11", and 175 pounds.
- Oh, nice little build.
- I need some more
excitement, he's a veteran!
- I have always loved a man in uniform.
Oh, these gorgeous shoulders.
(laughing)
These deltoids are ready to hold a baby
if I ever felt one, honey.
Remember last year in the
news, or like two years,
feel these traps!
Yeah, 'cause that chest is just like,
inviting me to lay my head on it.
Inviting me to lay my
head on it, you know?
And I wanna like, rip your
shirt down the middle,
and nuzzle in your nook.
- Don't do that. I don't have many left.
- And just, well I won't.
You have the cutest
smile, do you know that?
- No.
- It's like, the cutest smile,
it's like your moneymaker.
I know I said I would like,
swear to not be attracted to you,
and not make you feel uncomfortable,
but I just don't know if
I can like really keep
to that promise now.
(exclaims)
You're literally Jon Snow,
you're literally attractive,
all I want you to do is like, hold me,
I can't even handle it.
(laughs)
I can't handle how much I love it.
Look at this face.
Look at this handsome, gorgeous face.
Get out of here, you look gorgeous.
I'm obsessed with you.
Now I'm gonna tear your shirt off,
I'm just kidding.
That'll be on Wednesday.
(laughing)
We can't be close enough!
I'm obsessed with everything about you,
I can't even handle it.
Look at that walk in that heel, bitch!
Get away from me!
Oh my god, you look so good!
He's giving you angles,
he's giving you cheekbones,
he's giving me jaw, he's giving me
a full thick head of salt and pepper hair.
They're giving us The Jackson Five,
"The Partridge Family", "The Brady Bunch".
We meet Patrick Dempsey, you're
giving me take your top off,
you're giving me hold me
'til the pain goes away,
you're giving me like, strong
man, I will change your tire,
I will pay your bills, I will provide!
- I will do none of
those things, but yeah.
- You might!
Oh!
Okay, bye!